I think you've lost the plot here a little bit. I think you're
I think you're the tether's gotten your You're kind of floating
around in outer space. You're asking me saying that, man. I think
that's disrespectful. What? What do you mean? >> what a
lying piece of dude. This guy is just scum. Total scum. >> As
a as a holistic label. >> Yes. I'm not going to explain
this. I refuse. I simply refuse. >> You are a loser. You
are a jealous narcissistic loser who understands there's somebody
better than you at your job. And so, you are going to try to
tear them down because you're a bitter
But I just want you to understand because I think yes, my name
is at the top of the story because this is my reporting. This
is my reporting that I brought forward fundamentally. But if
you're going to take issue with like random sort of characterizations
and again I understand >> I don't think it's random. I
think it was deliberate. I think it was deliberate. Why don't
you get to there? I mean like I mean why don't you go there and
just ask Taylor >> the copy editor. >> I'm trying
to have a conversation with her. I don't know why you're jumping
in here. No, no, no. Because it's kind of a stupid critique to
be like, hey, um, you know, centrist is kind of the eyeholder
like Yeah. So, Joe Biden would describe himself as a centrist
Democrat. Correct. Yes or no?
>> Wait, wait. Can you answer that first? Can you answer
that? >> The question the question you should ask the question
you should ask is
the question that you should ask is >> if this article
is wrong and it's factually wrong, then I highly encourage them
to ask for a correction. But no one has asked. >> Can we
do it step by step?
are not centrists. No one. >> Let's just do it step by
step. Hutch, is it your contention that it's inaccurate to call
Olivia Juliana a centrist? >> I do believe that. Yes. And
I think that she's virtue of intentionally. Well, I don't know
why you're
saying
that word. It's a >> separate No, wait. No, hang on. So,
separate that intent. >> You guys are saying it's standard.
I'm saying I've never I have not seen it in other contracts.
That doesn't mean that it doesn't exist in some are you claiming
it's standard. You're not claiming it's standard, are you? Well,
based on what I looked into, this language would be consistent
with a 501c4 that is protected. >> Is it your claim that
it's standard or >> Hang tight, peace. We can talk in a
second. So, Taylor
doesn't want to answer you conveniently. >> The creator,
>> what I mean is that like the leftist anarchist people
on TikTok don't seem to be part of this program. I haven't seen
any of those people part of this program. I haven't seen those
people connected to >> being But not being radically left
is not the same thing as being centrist,
>> Right. I understand that, but I'm saying >> you're
complaining them. >> Okay. What What label to make you
happy so I don't trigger you with the wrong word? What >> something
reasonable? >> No. Okay.
The stupidest [__] point of all time that like the
the Democratic party is a center left party and we embrace that,
right? This show is called Live and >> Do you think Brian
Tyler Cohen is a >> Wait, wait, wait, wait. Hutch, hutch,
hut. Democratic party, hutch, hut, hut, hut. I don't care. You
need the name that you want. I hush. The the Democratic party
is a center left party. Is that correct? >> Is Brian Tyler
Cohen a centrist? Wait, wait. Hutch, can you answer one question?
Answer one question.
>> Answer one question. Is the Democratic >> You
answer mine. >> Well, let's talk about Taylor Loren. Let's
talk about that that pod. >> When you when you were interjecting,
was your goal to
>> Here was my sense of things. Tell me if I'm wrong. >> I
think you were >> I think there were a couple things going
on there. Maybe a few. I think the first thing that popped into
my mind was that
I suspected that you might have been wary of the optics of a
pylon. And so
you saw me and you saw me and and Soy Pill um kind of bouncing
off each other.
>> so like there's no way that you could have ever thought
that Taylor Loren wasn't like evil and wrong. And so when you
cut in, it was like basically you were trying to like make it
so that we didn't appear to be piling on Taylor Loren for being
evil and wrong because there's no way you couldn't think that
she was evil and wrong. That doesn't make any sense,
right? >> Uh well, you tell me. I mean, were were you trying
to did you meaningfully disagree with the points that I was making
or did you think that the arguments could have been sharper?
>> Some of them >> or did you think that like the
arguments could have been sharper and that's what motivated you
to >> jump in when you did? I guess that's that's an important
distinction to make in terms of disagreement. It depends on which.
>> So let's see the first jump in Hutch thought that Pisco
was basically just arguing that
basically he's arguing that Pisco was just trying to avoid the
optics of a pylon. Could we believe that based on what's going
on issue with the first interjection characterization and >> I
don't think it's random. I think it was deliberate. I think it
was deliberate. Why don't you get to there? I mean like I mean
why don't you go there and just ask Taylor >> the copy
editor. >> I'm trying to have a conversation with her.
I don't know why you're jumping in
just in my head just with baseball bat. I'm so sorry bro.
that's so insane. Uh I'm trying to have a conversation here.
Pisco. How about you stop jumping in?
These are friends by the way. These are friends, by the way.
Oh, Pisco, I was just And now he's gaslighting in this conversation,
too. Pisco, I thought maybe you were just trying to have like
you're trying to avoid the optics of a pylon. Does that sound
like he just thought Pisco was trying to make the podcast look
better when he responds? Does that sound like >> isue with
like random sort of characterizations? And again, I >> I
don't think it was random. I think it was deliberate. I think
it was >> Why don't you get to there? I mean, like I mean,
why why don't you go there and just ask Taylor >> the copy
editor? >> I'm trying to have a conversation with her.
I don't know why you're jumping in
>> Hey, pipe down. Pipe down. Pipe down. Bro, I was just
I was just, you know, I was thinking maybe you were a little
concerned about the optics of a pylon.
Dude, what a liar. What an obvious and provable liar.
Just totally just lying scum. And I don't know if he's doing
it for his ego or what, but gross. I can't imagine being friends
with this guy. He's actually a piece of like he's actually a
total piece of
sad. Very very sad. >> Why don't you get to there? I mean
like I mean why don't you go there and just ask Taylor?
>> I'm trying to have a conversation with her. I don't
know why you're jumping in >> No. Because
>> that rudeness that way that tone he takes trying to
be like Pisco it's so stupid that you try to he is invoking some
element of the people he knows hate Pisco knows that he knows
that they hate post about Pisco. He is incredibly aware of it.
He reads the Destiny subreddit all the time. He knows exactly
what he's trying to invoke there when he does that and like doubly
doubly so. Just total piece of Okay, Pisco's tiptoeing a bit.
Yeah, Pisco doesn't want to deal with that. And he knows that
if he actually stands his ground here, he's going to have to
deal with way more of it than if he doesn't. And I don't know,
like
I understand that might sound conspiratorial to some people,
but it's not. It's like clearly what's happening. this person
is like using I don't know why they feel justified in doing like
oh I I'm right and everybody says I'm right so obviously Pisco
is just crazy and he's trying to my greatness or something. I
have no idea why he thinks he's like a king why he why he thinks
he's so awesome. It's totally totally
unrealistic. Totally not the case. Everybody can see it who's
not already, you know, in a certain place.
But regardless of whether it was true or not, it's rude. It's
a thing to do to a friend. And Pisco doesn't even want to push
back cuz he doesn't want to deal with the whole thing about how
he's abusive to Hutch again. He's trying to be a good friend.
Pisco is holding back because he's trying to be a good friend.
And Hutch is going is being a complete douchebag to him because
I don't know. Surely nobody's going to, by the way, nobody's
going to unpack that or analyze it. That interjection right there
couldn't possibly be perceived as him being like overly defensive
of Taylor Loren either. I believe that's the first interjection
Pisco has in that whole thing. couldn't possibly be perceived
as him going to bat for Taylor or something. He was just going,
"Oh, I think it could be better this way." And Hutch immediately
cuts him down. Is totally condescending and rude. I'm going to
back it up. Right. And do you agree that that is a proper label?
And so why why is it a proper label? And that actually is effective,
I think, for you if you're able to say, "Well, all I mean by
centrist, if Taylor says, "All I mean by centrist is align with
the Democratic party." That's additional evidence that her calling
it out is not a good explanation in the It's not a good explanation
in the article to be like, well, I just wanted to make sure the
reader knew that Olivia Giuliani was aligned with the Democratic
party. That's all kind of presupposed in the fact that they're
a part of course in the first place. And so it lends more plausibility
to the argument that it's being used as an indicator, right,
as a framing device. And so rather than trying to like um to
bog you, >> Pu is just so correct in the in the like the
idea that whether or not Pisco is literally trying to help Hutch,
right? He's trying to say if Hutch just spent all of his time
and hinged his argument on whether or not Olivia Giuliana was
a moderate or a centrist or whatever, then he would be totally
defeated by the idea of her identifying as that. He would lose.
And he would lose the point he's trying to make. That 0% essentially
0% of your argument should hinge on whether or not Olivia Giuliani
is a centrist or a progressive. If you do that, you are setting
yourself up to get owned.
And now
because God is good, we have this precise clip of hers of Olivia
Giulianiana calling herself a moderate that proves Pisco's point
entirely because this clip right here shouldn't change your opinion
on whether or not that article was bias and not in my argument,
not in Soyel's argument, not in Pisco's argument. Only in the
way Hutch tried to argue it, right? Hutch is the only person
who is blown the out now because he didn't take Pisco's advice.
>> I beat you down. I was trying to do the opposite. I
was trying to be like, why are we talking about whether it's
true or not, whether she's a centrist? Let's just get clarity
on what Taylor meant and then go to the thing that matters, which
is the framing. >> On a second. Hold on a second. I just
want to see cuz I apparently I got a couple timestamps
and it's factually wrong. Then I highly encourage them to ask
for a correction. But no one has asked. >> Can we do it
step by step?
They are not centrist. No one. >> Let's just do it step
by step. Hutch, is it your contention that it's inaccurate to
call Olivia Giulianiana a centrist? >> I do believe that.
Yes. And I think that she intentionally Well, I don't know why
you're
separate.
It's a >> separate. No, wait. No, hang on. So, separate
that intent.
>> So, Pisco is saying Hutch
that you shouldn't be mixing these two arguments that they're
going to conflate and it's not you're not going to get the answer
you want. So you need to stop arguing about whether or not she's
a centrist because that's actually immaterial to whether or not
Taylor used it in a way that's projorative.
Immaterial. Okay. She could even if Taylor especially actually
especially if Olivia Giuliani is a centrist touch.
You you could make this argument even like more strongly. So
you shouldn't even be trying to argue it. You are actually up
by trying to argue it. And Hutch is getting condescending to
Pisco trying to save Hutch from his own doom. And it's possible
now that Pisco has saved touch from his own doom and Taylor Loren
won't quite get to dance on his grave the way she could have.
But Pisco is the person trying to help you, you bald.
>> So you can make a you can make a critique of an article
based on its accuracy or based on whether there's some ma bad
motive in that term to a >> Is it your contention? I know,
but let's just let's just do it step by step. Let's do it step
by step, right? Is it inaccurate? And so, and if it's inaccurate,
why is it inaccurate?
>> It's inaccurate because her policy priorities do not
line up with what any reasonable person would assert to be a
centrist when you >> I got so condescending the whole time.
And he's like so blown up. And Pisco is so vindicated. So, Pisco
is so clear about what he means the entire time. Right. The entire
time Pisco is perfectly clear about what he means. Hutch can't
understand because he's a [__] as well I was going
to say a [__] as well as but he's a [__]
and so he doesn't understand what Pisco is trying to do how Pisco
is trying to help him again we're we're once again in the world
where Pisco is like flying and he's trying to help Hutch he's
trying to grab Hutch by the hand and take Hutch flying over the
city and Hutch is like no
how can you jump so high no I don't like you NO STOP talking
I'm jumping right now
flightless bird man he's got no no ability no capacity he's not
like the of >> I think the the cleaner what I'm trying
to press for is just to ask her in what sense she's using centress
because there's no objectively correct definition of centress
is going to you're using it. Yeah. >> But so the question
itself like your interjection it presupposes good faith on the
on the part of of of uh Taylor. >> No, it doesn't. Dude,
it's actually so crazy that I've never seen somebody win this
hard in a like internet debate basically. Like I I feel like
I've never seen somebody win
this quickly in retrospect on a debate as hard as Pisco now wins
all of this. Right?
Because guess what? There's no presupposition of good faith here
at all. Pisco isn't doing that. And now now that you have Olivia
Giuliano saying I am a moderate Democrat, right?
Like Pisco has just proven correct that you should never have
been arguing about that in the first place. Totally totally correct.
Totally vindicated. Totally right. Every person who complained
about him totally wrong, too low IQ to understand, get the out
of here, >> friends. Well, I think it does because the
point of my line of questioning and so picked up on it was I
I don't think that she was using that word in good faith. I think
she I I'm I'm agree with you. I'm positive that she was using
it as a pajorative and the whole point of like pressing her on
like, well, how did you come to that conclusion? And then it
just laid bare that number one, she didn't even she wasn't even
prepared to answer like what what a centrist is. I mean, that's
pretty notable. And then also, you know, like the fact that it
applied to Juliana, it was just like I think it's pretty silly
when you look at >> Well, no, there are some senses when
she would be a centrist. >> Well, I mean, sure, but but
I I understand that. Sure. I I take your point, but at that point
in the conversation, I think it we in my opinion, I had already
kind of exposed that that she was using the term in a bad faith
way. And so when you did that,
I felt like I felt like it gave her a lifeline because now it's
like now I'm fighting you on the subjective nature of it and
we're moving away from the fact that she clearly used that label
in a a malicious way. >> Oh man, I had to make another
tweet. It's just uh I just have to lay this out that it's absolutely
proves that Pisco's interjection was necessary and required.
It's too bad that Hutchinson at Hutchinson is too much of a narcissist
to appreciate his friend trying to save him from himself.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Pretty >> I mean,
it's a subtle thing. You have to be kind of line and you have
to kind of What's the conclusion
in in online politics? But I think it was pretty obvious at that
point that that she got her caught with her hand in the cookie
jar. And so when you did that dispute No, no, no. that. So, so
my introduction does not presuppose good faith and I'll tell
you why. >> What's crazy about this entire conversation
is that Taylor's bias literally changes nothing but the substance
of the article. Well, it could change a little bit, Kilo. But
I would say that one, there's already a process in place to make
sure her bias doesn't doesn't take this into a place that's like
totally unreasonable, right? There's a bunch of other people
looking at this. It's not just her bias that's carrying this
narrative. It is the editorial staff as well. And so while at
the margins her bias might frame things like slightly differently,
right, it it doesn't tang it doesn't tangibly change it. And
the biggest issue is the lack of disclosure, right? The lack
of disclosure both from the people giving the money and the people
receiving the money. That's the biggest issue. And that is just
factually accurate. That is how this all went down. And despite
what these people argue, the total cope they try to argue about
whether or not the contracts enforced, they are wrong.
And that is improper. And it is good that they I mean it's great
that they
like they've been totally defeated on this. They're just totally
wrong. They're so obviously wrong. And I think most people can
see it. Most people do see it. So So give me give me a sense
of centrist which actually So your sense of centrist that you're
going to give me which is the gloal one. Give me that sense of
centrist. And then also make sure that whatever sense you're
giving to me does index as between these two different groups
that is to say commentators and >> I mean I would say like
I would say centism like centrist would be like more or less
synonymous with moderate. It could mean someone that has a decently
>> Oh no, he got wrecked. Wait, did Pisco know? Oh, do
you think Wait, do you think Pisco knew? Do you think he knew
about the moderate clip? Hold on, listen to that. Did Pisco set
this guy up? Oh, is Pisco a little Is he
one? Give me that sense of centrist and then also make sure that
whatever sens you're giving to me does index as between these
two different groups is to say commentators and politicians.
I mean I would say like I would say centism like centrist would
be like more or less synonymous with moderate. It could mean
someone that has a decently balanced >> Why is Hutch saying
that? Did I miss Po say something about preference? So maybe
>> but that's that's like it right like Hutch maybe had
the argument that centrus and moderate weren't the same. But
unfortunately
unfortunately he just confirmed
for everybody who's paying attention Hutch just confirmed that
he thinks Centress and Moderate are the same. So he would he
would have to concede it in the UV Juliana clip. Oh boy. >> I
think in the course of conversation we did demonstrate that centress
and by we I just mean like you and so I think in the course of
the conversation I don't know exactly when I would be convinced
you demonstrate that she was using it um as a pjorative. I don't
doubt that. In fact I I happen to agree that you did right. But
the question is did you demonstrate that at the >> I don't
think they did either. I actually don't think they demonstrated
it. I think you basically just attacked this person until they
folded. Honestly, I think I can see why Pisco thinks that because
Pisco can't conceive of basically people who who would fold in
a conversation like that. Like I think he it's just outside of
his conception that like and I hate to be overtly but women women
do this. Okay, women women are soft and and weak and they they
will just fold if you like yell at them enough. I'm I'm sorry.
I hate to be this guy who just says this, but this is the way
it is a lot of the time is you're talking to a woman and you're
like really aggressive about it and sometimes they will just
break down and like be like, "Oh, you're I don't know."
Right? They'll just say I'm
Listen, guys can do it, too. Guys can do it, too. But I'm just
saying I would just I
this is something that let me operate better in terms of like
companies I've worked at. If I'm going to talk to like marketing
or another department that's like more women, way more women
than obviously the engineering department where there's no no
women at all, right? Something that helped me understand is I
need to be like sort of like calm and be collaborative and not
ever be like aggressive or or direct in in suggesting somebody
up. Cuz as soon as you do that, a lot of people in those departments
who don't have like the kind of conversations that are like sort
of brutal and to the point, they will immediately feel like you're
accusing them of something and like clam up or say something
stupid that is like not helpful. You know what I mean?
And so you just have to talk in a different way. And I it's like
been very it's been beneficial me learning this kind of thing,
right? Very beneficial.
But it's
ah yeah but uh it's yeah I don't know how else to say it. That's
that's just the way it is.
And so
once you started like kind of berating her and she goes like
yeah it's it's like not really that important. I think she called
herself this which now we know she did.
me now. Maybe not in the article she talked about but I don't
know if she wrote another article where Juliana's reference.
I have no idea. But um she has reference talked about herself
this way. So now
oh now what what does it mean when she's like more defensive
after that when you guys keep pushing and keep pushing it keep
pushing you keep pushing it doesn't mean anything to me. I don't
think they proved anything. I think this is for people thinking
they bered a woman into like breaking down and admitting she's
manipulative when they just bered her until she like was saying
anything so you'd stop berating.
Maybe not quite like that, but like she's just like basically
like why didn't she just off and I don't think she thought about
it is is my point. I just don't think she really thought about
using that word. She just like threw it in there. And that's
by the way I still think she was probably she was probably thinking
that
how do I put it? She was probably like overall in the article
she had her bias. Like it is a bi it's bias a little bit in the
exact ways you'd expect for somebody with her politics. It's
not really that bad. >> At the time I interjected in my
in my
>> Didn't she say she didn't even write that line? No.
Well, she said she didn't write it. She said it was from a reference
that Olivia Juliana made about herself
and that she quoted in another article or something. >> Well,
in my opinion, I did because like as soon as she gives three
or four nonsensical, sometimes contradictory answers at that
point, it's like, well, wait a second, something fishy is going
on here. >> You saying it's nonsensical, right? Presupposes
some standard, right? You say it's nonsensical because the real
definition that's why we can't get around the semantic. But but
peace I don't even have to I don't even have to go down your
line of thinking here where there's some standard or subjective
standard and exploring what that means. I don't even need to
do that if I can reveal that she clearly didn't herself. She
clearly didn't give any thought as to what it meant for her to
call her a centrist. Unless >> Yes. So if she gave no thought
to it, what are you saying about intent there? You just said
you proved intent and you hutch, you just said she didn't give
any thought herself to why she said
So what bad faith could she be operating in? What intent could
she be operating with? Like unconscious biases?
Yeah, sure. I'll give you that. Some nefarious way of using it
as a pjorative to with this woman to like sort of signal that
all Democrats are bad or like I guess as a proof of as a smaller
piece to show that she's like she hates Dems. She wants them
to fail. No. Come on, man. >> I thought you said she was
using that label unless she was using that label in a pjorative
way. That's my point. Like, >> well, hang on. So, you asked
her. We >> The thing he just said is completely Oh my god.
>> Herself. She clearly didn't give her thought as to what
it meant for her to call her a centrist unless she was using
that label. Unless she was using that label in a por. >> She
gave no thought to whether or not she call why she was calling
this person a centros. Unless she was using it as a pjorative.
How in the world did you prove that way? >> Why, dude?
Pisco is actually being too kind in this conversation right now.
Like way too. Like he didn't prove this. This is not proven.
It's totally crazy to suggest that this is proven right now.
Unless I could possibly be forgetting some other she said or
the order she said it in. I don't have perfect recall of the
conversation as it progressed, but I do think that I to me I
don't feel like it was proven. I don't see it, man. Hutch's frustration
reminds me of like an animal caught in the fence and he's flailing
while Pisco tries to gently detangle him and Hutch is only thrashing
and getting more frustrated at the help. Yes.
Yeah. It's just like uh just like my my quote tweet of this where
I'm like, "Dude, Pisco is right." And and Hutch is too much of
a narcissist was my contention that he he's like angry at Pisco
for trying to help him. Pisco is like trying to save him and
and Hutch is like freaking out. Yeah. Taking basically trying
to bite Pisco as Pisco tries to >> That's my point. Like
>> Well, hang on. So you asked her, we we should actually
review what you said, but like if when you asked her um when
you were using the term centrist there, you don't think that
she's actually a centrist? And she said, no, I do think that
she is a centrist. And >> I don't think that's I think
I led by asking her like, "Well, what does that word mean to
you and why does it apply to her?" And then as soon as I did
that, that's when her answers like spiraled and she kind of she
she started to lose composure like within 10 minutes of our conversation
and get defensive and and I think at that point like it was obvious
that it was motivated by an agenda. So I don't even need to do
this whole like well you know it could have meant subjective,
you know, centrist could have meant that way to to Taylor and
and again I want to re again like it it shouldn't matter like
what it meant to her as like positioned as a leftist or appealing
to a leftist audience. If you're writing the article from a neutral
perspective, you should use the word the way that like most people
think of that word, not from the perspective of like an online
leftist. >> Right. So, so, so we have to demonstrate she's
in fact doing that, right? And not >> in my opinion. I
did. I did. >> I think I think you I think Pisco I think
you stretched that conversation out like you stretched out. >> Pisco,
you kind of sabotaged me. Pisco, like you kind of sabotaged me
with your interjection that actually like you actually with me.
Hey, Pisco that 30 seconds you talked for, you kind of me over
with that. You know, I was cooking in the in the 55 to 70 minutes
I spoke in that episode. Uh, I was kind of cooking and when you
took 40 seconds of my time away, that was reallyed up of you
actually. So, you assigned the label a centrist to Olivia Juliana,
which is how she selfidentified. Uh, no, she selfidentified as
a progressive, right? No, I from what I found my original reporting
back um from the New York Times back when I interviewed her,
she was identifying as a centrist Democrat in Texas. So, that
is you agree that's a coherent so just be clear, you agree that
it's a coherent thing to say. I'm going by >> Oh, man.
Oh, these people are so rude. It's like actually so over for
them.
I dude, it's actually so over. And I I can't believe
Pisco tried to save them. Pisco said you shouldn't make this
about a part of your argument at all.
>> It's not. >> By the way, by the way, Soy Pill
went out of his way to accuse Taylor of lying about that and
bring up the old reporting without looking at some of these new
clips where she's clearly like referring to it that way. And
And
apparently he got a phone call from Taylor.
According to him on his stream earlier, she wasn't happy about
that. >> It is. No, I don't think that's a defensible argument
because in in recent >> it's understandable, right? >> Understandable.
No, it's not. I'm saying it's not understandable. She she >> it's
coherent. You can understand the concept of it. I mean that it's
>> I can understand the concept of it, but what's the problem
with the problem with that piece though is that >> Oh,
I see. I see. We all thought Soy Pill was getting harassed, but
it looks like Soy Pill's participating in the gay baiting in
the in the que baiting. The only thing Po stretched was Hutch's
cheeks when he claps them. Wow.
Wow. Soy pill engaging in a little little queer baiting on the
side here. Let's go. W. >> You can understand the concept
of it. I don't mean that. >> I can understand the concept
of it. But what's the problem with the problem with that piece
though is that Olivia Giuliani has been selfidentifying as a
progressive since 2021.
And Taylor Loren in 2023 was calling Juliana a progressive. So
in this moment, she's just lying. She's like Taylor is just >> lying.
So So you need to establish that there's a in order for that
to be convincing evidence. I'm just telling you from a neutral
perspective. In order for that to be convincing evidence of inconsistency
in her lying, you would need to show that the notion of centism
is opposed to progressivism that they're counter contradictory.
>> Why do I need to show that agree with that? No, I don't.
I don't. Anybody anybody watching a political podcast, I don't
like >> now that he basically now that Hutch refused to
go through any of this exercise with Pisco, now that he refused
to listen entirely, the clip Pisco has produced actually totally
obliterates Hutch in every possible way. I I got to keep saying
it cuz it's just so delicious watching him be a narcissistic
piece of to Pisco and Pisco just totally won.
It's
I think Pisco should have just said, "Hey, a lot of people don't
think he won and looked insane. Hush will never rethink anything
because he won in his mind." Well, Pisco is trying to be softer
than that. That's what Pisco is trying to do. >> Like I
don't need to flesh this out. It's just on its face absurd.
>> Something being on its face absurd sounds like it's
saying like it's self-evidently that's what I'm saying. Yes,
I think it was self-evidently true that she was lying in that
spot. >> Something that's self-evident isn't justified.
You understand that? >> Justification, it provides a a
basis by which to come to a conclusion via an inference. But
self-evident is an >> Yes. I'm assuming that the vast majority
of everybody that was listening to the podcast understood that
she was contradicting herself and she was back she backed herself
into a corner. That's what I think most people in order for >> I
didn't need to flush it out. It was just like it was just laid
bare right there for everybody to see.
I I'm I'm just trying to establish like the kind of inferential
steps that someone would need to draw to say, "Oh, she's lying
caught." Right? Regardless of whether you stated them, right?
Someone would need to immediately hear upon hearing that you
called her a progressive before. They in order to say, "Ah, therefore,
you're lying." You would need to come to the conclusion that
being a progressive is incompatible with being a centrist. Otherwise,
it doesn't make sense as an own, right? It doesn't make sense
as an own unless you can show that centis and progressivism are
like oil and water. >> Let's pause for a second. >> Do
you understand what I'm saying? >> Not really. >> Let's
pause for a second. Let's pause for I understand what you're
you're meaning in the abstract. I I don't think you do, man.
>> I I I do I think I understand what you're meaning in
the abstract. I don't think you're applying it in a way that
makes sense because if you had to guess, just ballpark, everybody
in the audience that was listening to that podcast, what percentage
of them when they heard Taylor say that, you know, this the the
everybody listening to that podcast is somebody who's already
going to agree with you on everything? You cannot say, "Hey,
my audience, I did a poll in my audience and they think I'm a
big smart boy." Yeah, that's not an un dude. Are you serious?
Everybody watching this, everybody I've talked to, everybody
who who showed up to say I did really good, they all think I
did really good. No,
must be so strange to pretend to be friends with Hot Shift to
this. Well, the thing is like,
yeah, I don't Why would you be friends? And by the way, I know
I know Quean saw this. I know I'm not crazy. I saw it when Pisco
has that first conversation with Hutch about like, "Hey, we're
arguing." What were the What the were they arguing over? It might
have been over denims or something. I can't remember what it
was precisely. And every time Pisco is trying to explain something
earnestly to Hutch, Hutch makes these stupid faces into the camera.
And it's like, dude, you can actually be bad faith and and like
trying to spite trying to be spiteful to one of your friends
because you make a you make a face into the camera. Every time
they're talking, making a point to you, you make a face like
they're a total [__] who's saying incomprehensible
garbage. Yes, obviously that's what you're doing. Obviously,
you're trying to make your friend look bad. Isn't that why Josiah
popped off on him? It wasn't just the faces. Is also the he was
saying, right?
And and it is like bad faith. It is like it's it's it's disingenuous.
I'll say maybe it's not bad faith. It's disingenuous. And you're
a total piece of And now Hutch is doing the same thing. And he's
like signaling to all the people in his chat who's telling him,
"Oh, Pisco is just too Pisco's like I don't understand what Hutch,
you've got an ADIQ chat who can't ponder conditional hypotheticals.
They'll never know what they felt like or what they would feel
like if they didn't eat breakfast this morning. They'll never
be able to figure it out. That will be beyond them for the rest
of their lives. Not unlike it's beyond you." Okay? So, when they
tell you you're winning, that should be the first indicator that
you're losing. All right? Anything your chat says, anything these
complete and utter drillants say to you should be an indication
of to of the opposite. It should be an indication that whatever
they're saying the opposite is true. They're morons. You're a
[__] I know I'm so I'm giving you an easy rule. If
your chat is telling you something, if they're telling you you're
doing good, you're probably making a fool of yourself.
If they're telling you you're doing bad, you're probably actually
winning. Just saying. That's that's the way this is. Okay. So,
enjoy. I guess enjoy that. enjoy having these gas you up so you
humiliate yourself for my pleasure, my content. Please keep doing
it. Please never give up because I know I'm going to keep farming
your ass
for as long as you keep going.
It's just
You're free. Any of these Destiny reactions, they're all free.
You people are too lazy to do your jobs, and you're not smart
enough to make an argument. So, I get to farm you for free forever.
Awesome. Trade deal accepted. Thank you very much. >> Okay.
And she she's not a moderate. Got it. No, I don't think she is.
No. >> All right. But why is that in contradiction with
progressive? Help me out there. Because that's the kind of the
claim that that she contradicted herself and she proved she was
lying is she called her a centrist and centrist is moderate and
then she's previously called her progressive. And so if we're
going by those definitions, there needs to be some contradiction
or some kind of like tension between moderate and >> I
think you've lost the plot here a little bit. I think you're
I think you're the tether's got your you're kind of floating
around in outer space cuz you're asking me saying that. I think
that's disrespectful. What do you Well, I'm trying to be direct
with you because you you've now reached a point where you're
like, well, you know, you have to establish there's a difference
between moderate and progressive and it's a political podcast.
So, I I just like what are we doing like this does not need to
be explained to our audience that there well, you first have
to have to establish there's a difference between moderate and
progressive. No, I no I don't. I don't need to explain that.
That is firmly understood by >> I'm trying to understand
in your view, right? Like I'm not saying that you need to do
the conversation in this way and sus out the difference between
moderate and centrist. I'm trying to follow your train of thought
and showing and you said that you it was obvious by that time
that um >> you're not though you're not you're not trying
to find my train of thought. You're bogging the conversation
down or like now you got to demonstrate. >> Sorry, I was
grabbing some caffeine there and he was condescending as again.
He was condescending as
it's so funny watching this person who is incapable of like understanding
what Pisco is saying. Totally incapable of processing information
be condescending.
I can't handle it, man. I cannot handle
The morons.
The
What a fantastic [__]
I can't handle it when they get condescending, too. It's too
much, man. It's just too much. Every It's too much. It's too
much.
I'm afraid the snarking of Hutch must continue. At at best, or
sorry, at worst, we're keeping this guy's ego in check. Okay,
because no, apparently nobody else is going to do it. If I'm
the only person who is keeping this guy's ego in check, so be
it.
Until somebody else, until one of Pisco's friends is willing
to step in and say, "Hey, Hutch, you're being a condescending
piece of shit." Well, I assume he's going to keep being a condescending
piece of
Pisco's basically concerned about defending himself, it seems
like, because when he defended himself the last time when he
said, "No, that's not what's happening." He got told and he got
cracked down on by a bunch of bigger communities. Okay. One bigger
community, right, who all said he was being bad faith and he
went, "Oh, I guess so." Cuz nobody stood up and did what was
right. Will nobody stand up and do what's right. Will not a single
person stand up and say, "You know what? This ised up." I don't
want to see this guy get crushed by a total
This guy who's actually got promise. This guy who actually makes
arguments. This guy who's actually capable of defending like
his beliefs. I don't want to see him get crushed by complete.
Will nobody stand up? Will not a single person stand up? Well,
I guess it's going to be me
and my slight friend. Okay, it's just the two of us. Apparently,
we're the only guys. I said
I think Queenman wasn't covering this stuff. And the other night,
I was talking to Queenman off stream and I'm like, "Dude, they're
going to they're going to peace go. I don't want I don't want
it to happen." He's like, "Well, what what can I do?" I'm like,
"Well,
you know, you can try you can try try to do something. You're
going to wreck this guy. You got to save them. >> The lie
is that Olivia Juliana Juliana is a centrist. That's the lie.
Okay. And it's a lie. >> Just unequivocally,
brutally, anim
aped. Okay. Aped in every sense.
It's it's it's in virtue of her having called her a progressive
before. No intentional false that with all the other pieces of
evidence that we've compiled in this trial, you know, like in
other words, are you suggesting is it enough to know that she
called Olivia >> in this trial? That's telling, is it not?
Is that not telling of the mindset here? Is that not telling?
And all the other things we've collected in this trial. This
is rough. I I can just tell you personally, if I had parts of
my career tied to this guy, I would be looking to get away in
any way I could. I wouldn't want any association with this [__]
Like, he is he's being a narcissistic [__] He's totally
letting his chat denigrate his friend. Doesn't care about the
friendship at all. Trying to make his his friend look as bad
as possible here. Like, intentionally trying to make his friend
look as bad as possible here. and he will think after this that
he is the victim that he is the one who has been >> progressive
before to know that she's lying about calling her a central >> not
necessarily but when you weigh that up against the fact that
Juliana
on that right no but I didn't do that piece I established like
multiple pieces of evidence I didn't just I didn't just focus
on that I I appealed to I don't know six or seven different things
you know like Taylor's previous language not >> given that
it's not enough to identify that she's uh previously called her
progressive and um she now called her centrist and now she's
lying it must mean that it's possible to be a progressive and
a centrist on your view on your own view not on my view on your
No, you could explain the you could explain the discrepancy in
different ways. You could say that her thinking on Julia Olivia
evolved. No, I don't accept your premise that you can be both
moderate and progressive in the way. >> No, no, no, no.
That's I'm saying that that's an element of your view if you
think that it's not enough to say
everybody thinks this way. I mean, I just maybe I'm projecting.
>> Nope. Not everybody thinks this way,
>> I'm shocked that you feel you can speak for everybody.
>> Everybody else thinks you're like a weird freak. You're
like a weird freak puppet that is being manipulated around for
someone else's ends. You have no sensience. You have no thought
process. You have no autonomy. You are just being manipulated
and you can't see it. Everybody else is like, "Oh, look at this
sad weird little man." That's what everybody else thinks about
that regardless of everyone thinks this way. Okay. Then it applies
to everyone including you. All I'm saying is on your view, right?
You I thought I just heard you say that it's not enough to show
uh in basically in combination with other things that you're
able to assess that she's lying about the centrist point, including
the progressive point. Uh including the fact that she called
her progressive previously. In other words, >> they're
not contradictory innately, right? just to be a progressive is
not mutually exclusive being a centrist on your own your view.
>> No, it is it isn't in our for our purposes. Yes. Maybe
for someone who is a normie and has no idea about politics and
but in our spaces between you and me on the podcast my me directly
with Taylor our audience all of us understand these words to
be different descriptors that mean different things >> because
centress means moderate and moderate can't be progressives right
>> when we're using not no you keep doing the thing piece
go you're you're now >> you're using your sense of the
word centress. No, no, no. You're you're changing the word. You're
changing the word from a descriptor about the person and you're
stretching it to be a descriptor about their actions. And so
you're saying, "Well, a moderate can do progressive things."
That's not what we're talking about. We're talking about language.
>> I'm only talking about identity. I'm only I'm only talking
about identity here. I'm not talking about action. >> No,
you are though. You're saying you're saying a progressive can
do moderate things. That's like a label about their >> I
I understand that before I asked whether Bernie Sanders can be
centrist in some more narrow sense. That's not what I'm doing
right now. I'm asking if you are that is to say identify as a
moderate. Is it incompatible globally for you to identify as
progressive? >> Yes. As a as a holistic label? Why? Yes.
I'm not going to explain this. I refuse. I simply refuse. >> He
literally can't. He knows he can't.
He He literally He knows that he actually can't explain it. He
doesn't know how to. And so he's just going to keep saying he
won over and over again with no idea of why.
Cool. So cool. >> I'm not going to explain. I'm not going
to explain to you. I'm not going to explain to you why, especially
in our circles, that you cannot call yourself
>> Like, this is just Hutch
refusing to engage with his friend and trying to make him look
stupid, trying to make him look bad in front of all of these
people. I assume some of these people from DG. I don't know,
but I assume some of them are. He's going to try to make them
look bad in front of these people. He's going to try to get other
people to go after Pisco, and it will work. After this conversation,
I'll declare it. After this conversation, if Pisco tries to treat
Hutch like he is capable of any level of sincere
thinking, like any intellectual capable of any intellectualized
exercise, I will think he is abusive because you're abusing Hutch
by trying to treat him as a sensient regular person. He is not.
He's shown himself to be incapable. So after this, I will agree
with DG. If you keep treating Hutch like a human being worthy
of dignity and respect, like a human being who's capable of making
an argument, you are being abusive. He is disabled. He is functionally
disabled. Okay? Treat him that way from now on or you are abusive.
When he speaks, you just go, "Oh, that's cute, Hutch. That was
nice of you. That was cute. Oh, you you're doing so good, Hutch.
That's what you should do. That's the only way you could treat
this guy ever going forward. He has shown himself to be incapable.
He is a total uh what would the word be? He's just anti-intellectual
completely totally engages in every type of thought der
engages in every type of thought termination under the sun as
much as he possibly can because he never wants to argue his own
points at any time. He's stuck. He goes, "Oh, what do you think
I mean? What do you think I mean? What do you think I mean?"
Start saying if you are capable of speaking then speak little
one. Okay? Don't don't keep it to yourself. Explain to me where
the contradiction is. Explain to me where the lie is. Stop asking
me to fill in your thoughts for you. Speak for yourself
and don't make a stupid face when I tell you to do it.
Either start asserting that this guy has some level of thought,
some level of consciousness. either force him to engage or stop
treating him like a regular person.
It can no longer be this weird in between where you pretend that
he's like got something to say and he's just barely like not
getting it out. No, he's not even attempting it. He's not even
attempting to engage. Okay, he's not even remotely attempting.
So, stop doing the in between. call this out
on his or
stop pretending that you're you can have a conversation cuz he
can't. Ah, it's impossible. Another tweet to show that she is
assigning herself the progressive label. >> Okay. Okay.
Show me. Yeah. Give me that. No, but that's that's the whole
thing that we're like disputing, right? Is whether you're not
I'm saying she's a progressive. You're disputing that. You're
disputing that. >> And by progressive, you mean as counterpoints
to moderate? >> I'm not going to I'm not going to continue
to explain to that. >> No, I'm not going to cuz we've already
we've already been down that road. I've already explained it.
She said the argument though. She said, "You say, "I'm not a
progressive yet. I have very progressive stances. I believe in
a robust public option with Medicare available to all. I believe
in free community colleges and trade schools. I believe that
we need more immigration judges, more work permit, more visas,
comprehensive, clear pathway to citizenship." And so on and so
forth and on and on and on. Like she's saying like in this tweet,
she's saying like, "You don't you don't call me a progressive?"
And then list all her progressive bonafide. So like clearly she
selfidentifies and has for years as a progressive. And Taylor's
whole thing was like >> mutually exclusive and moderate.
>> Obviously. Yes.
>> In every context. In the global context. >> No.
in in our context piso like you can find a context where whatever
but in our context for our purposes in this conversation in the
conversation with Taylor they are mutually exclusive to Biden
let's let's deal with Biden all right so this is why I brought
up the Biden example right all so Biden you would agree is a
moderate
>> I would agree that Biden
ran on a moderate aesthetic in 2020 but also at the same time
did run on progressive policies >> I didn't ask if he ran
on I'm asking of the identity is he I'm not equivocating so in
the same sense that Jana is uh a moderate or not a moderate was
Joe Biden a moderate I colloquially people would probably call
Biden a moderate. Sure. >> Okay. And by moderate we mean
centrist because they're >> sure yes. >> And was
Joe Biden progressive? Yes or >> In in practice you mean?
>> No. I just mean as an identity. Would you identify as
a progressive? Yes or
>> I honestly don't even know. Does How did he self-escribe?
>> Hold on. >> Regardless of how he does, do you
understand what you just did? Right. If you say I don't know,
you had a problem because on your view there >> No, I'm
saying I don't No, I'm saying I don't know how he like calls
himself. But again, like the reason why I think like there is
a different standard for politicians is because they're playing
a different kind of game. And so somebody could intentionally
give off the aesthetic of being a moderate if it meant, you know,
more
equivocating, right? I'm not equivocating. I'm asking in the
same sense. I'm asking in a different sense. >> How does
this apply? So how does this apply to the Libya situation? >> What's
the right if it's possible for on your view for you to be unsure
regarding whether Biden is a progressive, but to be sure that
he's fairly called moderate, then they're not necessarily >> I
shouldn't have to explain to you that there are different factions
of the Democratic party. is especially especially relevant in
online discourse where it's 10 times more tribalistic than in
the real world. And so you know that when somebody says centrist
they are like you're trying it's like you're trying to create
a permission structure here. You're trying to create an explanation
for uh >> I'm not against dude. >> No but that's
what that's what you're doing though. You you are trying to you're
accusing me of being nefarious. You're saying I have a bad motive
micious motive. That's what you're accusing me of. No, I'm not
saying you have a nefarious motive. I don't know what motivates
you. All I can do is
>> you are trying to imply he's nefarious. You absolutely
are. Why are you Dude, stop lying. Oh my god.
Do you think Hutch is maybe actually good for the show as a heel?
Yeah, but unfortunately for him, he thinks he's you can't be
a heel without realizing you're the heel, right? Like you can't
Everybody who's a LCA without realizing it. Like there's no connection.
They don't understand the process they're going through. They're
setting themselves up for a fall. Now, if you guys want to all
make this guy the heel, you want to make him the heel, you want
to set him up and have him make arguments, the guy who's got
a history of addiction, who clearly has like some some mental
health issues as well, you want to set him up to consistently
make bad arguments, and then when when eventually the jig's up
and you all realize he's a total idiot, and you all walk away,
what do you think's going to happen? Are you guys ready to accept
responsibility for this?
I I hope so. Just accept responsibility when what's going to
happen happens
cuz I can see what's going to happen when you all lie to this
guy and say he's corrected and you gas him up like this so he
can go and fight with people. I see what's going to happen. I
hope you guys do. >> You're trying to create a permission
structure. That's implying that's saying that I'm being malicious.
>> Why? I try to clean up what I'm saying. I don't think
it's quite a permission structure. And so you know that when
somebody says centrist they are like you're trying it's like
you're trying to create a permission structure here. You're trying
to create an explanation for uh >> I'm not against >> No,
but that's that's what you're doing though. You you are trying
to have you're accusing me of being nefarious. You're saying
I have a bad motive, malicious motive. That's what you're accusing
me of. No, I'm not saying you have a nefarious motive. I don't
know what motivates you. All I can do is you're trying to create
a permission structure that's implying that's saying that I'm
being malicious. >> Well, I tried I tried to clean up what
I'm saying. I don't think it's quite a permission structure.
But I think you're trying to explain Taylor's writing in a way
that could be defensible when it's already firmly been established
in my >> But he already said it's not. Yeah. Exactly. Right.
So Pisco is seeing it. Pisco sees through the matrix. I think
Pisco just isn't like aggressive and angry about it in a way
people expect. People are like, "Oh, Pisco Pisco is such a She
just lets these people walk all over him." He's saying what's
happening. Pisco is saying it out loud. Pisco is saying what
you're doing when you say that I'm like trying to defend her.
You're creating permission structure for people to attack me.
You're doing that intentionally. You can see it. Pisco sees it.
He's just saying he's saying what's happening. Well, then he
lets it happen. But what? Hold on. How do you let it happen?
It was going to happen because Hutch did it. He's just pointing
it out. He's just keeping score. Pisco is like the guy who doesn't
have like a huge crash out where he keys your car and like leaves,
right? He's just going to be gone one day. That's all. He just
won't answer your calls. He'll just stop picking up the phone.
That's all he's doing. He's just like keeping track. He's like,
"You understand what you're doing, right?" Well, now you understand.
Do you see what your chat's doing, Hutch? Do you see what this
is? All you just did this whole struggle session with me and
Destiny like 6 months ago, 9 months ago, where you talked about
how the chat was super mean to you and it really bothered you
and now your chat's going hard on me. You're egging it on. And
then what are you going to do here? You're going to pretend you
don't understand what's happening when we literally had this
Of course, you understand what's happening. There is there are
a couple people two people in my private life who watch that
encounter are not deadender communists and socialists who are
not like clued in on who Taylor Ren is uh who like you are or
or anything like or like don't have that like and they thought
you were a total [__] Yeah, that's unfortunately
that's what everybody thinks in that conversation. You have to
be in the cult to misunderstand the Taylor Loren conversation
and think that Hutch looked good there. Hutch looks like a deranged
He looks deranged. I just to watch it.
>> Like a strong foundation like the overall drama and
they thought you were unhinged and they thought the trailer was
like being bullied and stuff and they didn't understand the point
about this interesting. Now I understand that okay with that
kind of that's fine. >> Okay. Okay. Uh Hutch just argued
about a reasonable person. Pisco goes I think a reasonable person
doesn't agree with you. And he goes I don't care. That's fine.
Okay. Then what were you arguing?
What he was arguing was, "All the people in my chat sure do agree
with me, man."
Well, I'm sure, listen, uh, as said by every single infamous
[__] who's ever done internet politics, as said by
Dave Rubin, as said by Candace Owens, as said by T, uh, [__]
Tim P, as said by all of these people, right? Oh, well, my chat
agrees with me, so I'm smart. Yeah, good luck. Good luck with
that. >> My brother My brother in liberalism. I'm just
thinking, um, yeah, if I'm going into a debate with someone and
I have a certain goal, >> who do you debate? You're like
a
totally deranged. Who do you debate? You run from everybody who
wants to actually debate you is like a an actual disagreement
with you. You're just a
What are you talking about? When I go into a debate, who do you
debate? Who do you ever debate?
>> Goal in mind. Like there have been some debates that
I've had where after the fact I thought it was like more of a
mixed bag. Some debates where I had where I thought it was just
bad. Some debates where I thought I was stronger. But I never
go into it with the hope that I'm going to convince literally
everyone that's watching that debate that
I'm correct about a thing or I've exposed some thing or something
like that. And so, you know, the fact that you have a couple
people in your life that thought that I was unhinged, I just
kind of expect that. But I know the work that I put into that
prep. I know the like the effort that I made during the conversation
to not be um belligerent or >> I went to great lengths
to not be belligerent. Uhhuh.
Uhhuh. Dude, get this guy get this guy back on the majority report.
Get him on Kyle Kolinsky. Get him on all these things. Make him
aware. I know, by the way, I know that everybody's watching this.
Like so many people are tuned into this watching this like total
implosion of this entire sphere, right? like the the obvious
bad faith that's happening just from when Piso sticks his head
up and goes like, "Hey, uh I think you guys are kind of being
like way too crazy about Hzan and everyone like directing attacks
at him after that." I think everyone else on the internet can
see exactly what's happening right now and
we'll see. I think a lot of other people could be making content
on this man. I think there's going to be a lot of content coming
out about this >> unacceptably like hostile and I feel
confident in my debate performance that night. Like I think I
I think I did a
I think that overall >> horrible for I thought that was
horrible. And I just want to say real quick I just want to say
real quick like >> I don't like that is a fundamental disagreement
when it comes to the debate that you and I have because
>> it's hard for me to to understand instinct to to jump
in when you did after I think I think it was just really obviously
exposed that she was not operating in good faith like at that
point like once somebody does that in the way that she was >> how
did you expose that Hutch because it proves she was lying what
did she lie about Hutch Pa come on man what do you think she
lied about no I'm asking you, Hutch. Come on. You're like kind
of bad faith right now.
It just keeps circling around over and over and over and over
>> Doing. So, I don't It's hard for me to understand your
instinct in that moment to not just let the bad faith just be
more and more >> just, you know, expose itself more and
more during that conversation. Instead, you jumped in to like
try to help her with the argument and try to help her defend
herself. And >> you're assuming that's what I was trying
to do. >> That is what you did. >> He just keeps
he just keeps saying it again, right? Piso goes, "I agree with
you. I'm saying you are doing a bad argument right now. Both
of these things could be true. That she could be guilty. She
could be wrong. And you're making a horrible argument." >> Did
that is what you did. >> Wait. When you said I did that,
you're saying with the intent, right? You're saying you went
to go help her.
>> Okay. But I'm telling you now that my intent isn't just
to help her. My intent is number one to express my view, right?
To express what I think about a given issue. And so it's not
couch.
>> Heo and Taylor get along because they're both deceptive
in similar ways. I hope Hutch will be able to see that
>> in terms relative to Taylor. People I know that's like
bizarre that I can have my own thoughts that aren't necessarily,
you know, done with >> we'll get like an evenhanded look
at this stuff, right? Like when uh like if Desi pulls this up,
he's going to get a give an even-handed look at this, right?
We're going to get the same thing. Oh, Hutch. Actually, when
you're like consistently not answering PCO's questions and implying
he's being bad faith and then like your audience is all on him,
that's creating a really bad dynamic. You're not being a good
friend. We're gonna get that same combo, right? For sure. 100%.
That combo, that combo was just genuine. And Desi was worried
about the friendship between Hutch and Pisco. So, obviously,
we'll get the reciprocal combo now and not, you know, nothing
or Desi just piling on to Pisco, right? For sure. For for sure.
But yeah, I think that's that intention of helping any particular
person, but you know, that is the case. And then also to streamline
the conversation to an area that actually matters and that isn't
just like talking past each other about the correct definition
of centrists or like whether she is in fact a centrist, but just
like accepting some semantic clarity in the nature of conversation,
which at least on its face should be conducted in good faith,
even if we don't assume good faith on the interlocator's part.
I'll reiterate again that I I I like sparring with you and I
actually think it makes for good content and um you know like
>> in our exchanges I have to be a little bit more sharper
and so like I I like appreciate that challenge challenge and
all that stuff and so I >> it's not personal for >> No,
you don't. You absolutely don't appreciate that challenge or
else you wouldn't be doing this whole signaling act that you
do where you try to get other people to attack him because you're
embarrassed that you don't understand what's going on and so
you're trying consistently to have other people attack Pisco.
You are a loser. You are a jealous, narcissistic loser who understands
there's somebody better than you at your job and so you are going
to try to tear them down because you're a
That's all that's happening. Okay? You're a bitter tiny.
So, keep trying to signal to this bigger audience, keep trying
to get Pisco torn down when we can all see that he's better than
you at this, that he's better than basically all of his contemporaries
at this.
and we'll keep we'll keep riding along. We'll all be
It's so sad to watch. It's it's sad to watch that this guy seemed
to be a good person and and the the more he gets the the closer
he gets to like a specific community, the worse he is as a person.
yeah, I don't know how else to say it. He's just obviously like
a worse human being at this point. Remember like a year and a
half ago where he's like, "I really, you know, I feel bad for
Pixie and like I could still forgive Destiny in like 5 years
if he showed contrition." Where did any of that go? The guy who's
like, "Oh yeah, I through my steps of recovery through NA or
AA, I can't remember. I've like learned about, you know, to get
to seek forgiveness, you have to show contrition."
Where's the contrition, Hutch? Where's all of that? Where's it
at, Hutch?
Nothing. You just gone. You've you gone. You've aligned with
that community. Now you're attacking a guy who's actually friends
with you, who actually has tried to support you. You're you're
sicking that community on him. It just seems a little to me.
That's me personally. >> I genuinely mean that. I don't
I I swear to you, I do not ascribe some nefarious intent. I get
confused sometimes. Like that's where this comes from. I get
confused because I don't >> Okay, I Now I'm going to Now
I'm going to lose it. He's I I feel like he's just lying here.
I feel like he's just lying here. You can't unless unless he
believes nothing that he said about denims. The whole thing about
seeing the chat, but I see him continue to look over. I feel
like he's looking at the chat. He sees all the chat pisco,
right? I haven't seen him go, "Whoa, guys, you're going way too
hard on Pisco. Ease up." I haven't seen anything. Mods, take
care of the people who are on my friend. Nothing. Not once.
Maybe the me raising the Biden point, you know, on reflection
just like by the way we just did now is exposing some potential
tension in your own view, right? Like we just went this whole
exchange and you said you're not sure if Biden's a progressive.
This is this is like the whole thing. Hutch thinks this is his
moment to get Taylor Loren. Pisco wants to understand Taylor
Loren and understand what's going on. Pisco has good faith engagement.
Like unironically, Pisco doesn't want to get he's not about getting
Taylor Loren, right? He's about showing basically in a way that
Taylor Loren herself couldn't argue against that she like had
a bias here cuz he doesn't think Taylor Loren is a bad person.
But Hutch thinks Taylor Loren is evil and so he has to expose
I would just argue that if you want to have people on your podcast,
don't have people on that you think are evil and need to be exposed.
That's clearly what Hutch was doing the whole time. And that's
that's what's really breaking down here is Hutch things. He doesn't
care if he was correct. He doesn't care if he's if he's um right.
He just wants to win. He's Dan in this moment, right? He just
wants to win. He just wants to he just wants to break down Taylor
You Taylor Loren, you stupid.
That's where Hutch is at.
And
I think I think basically everybody else in the podcast is like
probably maybe wanted to talk to her. I don't know. Although
I I maybe not. I don't know. I I actually don't know at this
point because it it just seemed like certainly I was fine sitting
Soy pill was sitting back and laughing as Hutch did it. So like
I have a hard time believing it. Now Hutch is invoking Soy Pill
saying Soy Pill totally agrees with him, right?
That this was like a good way to go about this. So hey, maybe
>> so Taylor is wrong because Olivia explicitly rejects
the label of centrist which is actually the more important point
and also selfident >> just to be clear Taylor when asked
clarified centrist Democrat. She selfidentifies as a centrist
Democrat
ar it's an article about Democrats she selfidentified as a centrist
Democrat. These people are just all lying because they can't
handle the fact that they got blown out by Taylor Loren again
>> identifies as currently. So she's just wrong. That's
not open for debate. And and her example of rejecting it is when
she said 20 whatever 18 months ago I was just a centrist in uh
classes and now look at or whatever she said there. That's her
rejecting the label. >> Yes. Obviously.
>> So what do you say about her um in terms of uh you know
the following statement? >> Taylor didn't see that. >> That's
her job. Are you kidding me? >> Do you remember? She's
the reporter. Hang on. But if you're going to use the word centrist,
you should go to the person's Twitter feed. You should look at
what they're about. You should search for the word centrist.
You should search for the word progressive. You should do your
job. You It's not good to be like, "Oh, okay." So, what you're
saying is
you should do your job. Further, our conversation from Live and
Learn, this is a clip of Olivia Juliana from 2025 describing
herself as a moderate
And I, matter of fact, I would tell you for a fact it's not normal.
Um, me even me saying that is is like a that's a no no. And I
know that because I'm too far right for
>> she's too far right compared to the lefties. She's too
far right because she dares to be a moderate Democrat. She's
not saying that she's a moderate in comparison to them. She is
saying she is a moderate Democrat, which is too far right for
the lefties. No other possible interpretation. If you think there
is, you are coping.
I just want the cope to stop. Can we get the cope to stop? Soy,
Bill, Hutch, could could you guys stop coping? I need the cope
to stop.
>> It's just bad reporting. Okay, f like I will concede.
Maybe it was just bad reporting. Sure. Fine. you're making the
argument that okay so there's a couple of explanations I think
that you need to go down is like either we're hanging her hat
on a progressive centrist um on Taylor's view being contradictory
or that um she knowingly ascribed her in order for her to be
wrong in so far as and it shows that she's lying she would need
to knowingly misidentify or mislabel her when she knew right
she knew that she wasn't a centrist and she called her anyway
and that point I think is I would that's like an issue that I
didn't want to get into and the reason I didn't get into is because
she could just be like I didn't see that all right she can and
exactly what she did which was like okay if she wants to update
it I will if it's wrong that's exactly what she did. And so it's
not useful as a point unless you're already bought into the fact
that she sucks. It doesn't advance anywhere cuz she can just
plausibly claim and unless you already think she's a piece of
[__] be like, "Oh, I didn't see that. I guess I'll
update it. I thought that she was a centrist. That was my understanding."
>> Yep. And that's exactly what I'm saying. There's a concept
of like malicious negligence. So, you know, is it possible that
Taylor just didn't think to look up her Twitter feed to see if
she needed to update her priors or her politics changed over
time? Like, sure. But she made a choice to do that. And I think
she made a choice to do that because she was already fond of
that label for a different reason. She was using that label to
smear Olivia Giuliani.
Oh, they're a progressive in 2023.
These people are so dumb.
Dude, I just every it's so it's such a hack for this content
knowing that Pisco already found this clip. And Hutch goes, "If
you weren't lazy, if you if you wanted to do your job at all,
then you would have looked this up before making any claims."
And then Pisco's like, "I guess I looked it up and look, I look
what I found." Like, you should publicly apologize. You actually
there is the only acceptable response to this from Hutch. He
is a complete loser. Complete piece of if he does anything but
go live and say I need to apologize to Pisco because I totally
blew him up and he was correct. I'm wrong and he was correct.
That is the only you have to do a full makulpa here or you are
a you are a garbage human being. a lot of
people in the left content creator space. Uh because I dare to
be a moderate
>> she's too far right for a lot of the people in the the
leftwing content creator space, right? >> The left content.
>> Yeah. Hold on. Is like a That's a no no. And I know
that because whatever she said no for a lot of people in the
left content creator space. I'm too far right for a lot of people
in the left content creator space. Uh >> because I dare
to be a moderate Democrat. See >> because I dare to be
a moderate Democrat. It would not be of note to say that Olivia
Juliana is centrist on that meaning of the word. So that's why
I think that she >> What does it mean to say it would not
be of note? What does that mean? In other words, it's superfluent.
It's redundant, right? It's like saying an unmarried bachelor,
right? If you say an unmarried bachelor, it's redundant. Like
wait, why are you saying something that's so trivial? What other
plausible uh reason would you have for saying something like
the democratic aligned centrists by which I mean democratic aligned
if you're not using that term when you have a track record of
using it as a pjorative that's why I think it's useful to get
to the semantic uh and the emptiness of her stated usage of that
word and that's effectuated by asking her hey what do you >> do
you see do you see the second Pisco starts talking with a spine
this whiny
this tiny spineless
just puts his hands in his in his lap now Pisco's using his big
boy voice with me. Oh no. Oh no. What a
Every every person with an ounce of masculinity gets heated when
somebody gets heated like this at them. This little mans the
down every single time. What a
what a disgusting wretched he is. >> You mean by this word?
And she says I mean democratic line. Oh, really? That's what
she meant? Then why even say that? >> Did she use the word?
No. No. You're telling me kind of in a sense what it isn't, but
I'm saying what is it? So like did she use the word specifically
to paint Juliana as a villain? >> As DNC a villain. Yes.
What are we >> Then why are we doing all this? >> You
ask me why are we doing this?
>> You didn't let Taylor answer her definition of why Juliana
is a centrist. Actually, she did. And now we find out that first
thing she said is correct. That when she said, "Well, actually,
last I checked, she selfidentified as this." And so I just didn't
think anything of it. That answer was just correct, by the way.
So, she wasn't lying and you guys bered this woman until I guess
she had some inconsistency there. I don't And that's totally
it's totally unknowable whether that is because she was being
bered or whether that is because she was hiding something.
And by the way, I don't even think like I don't think it super
matters to me because nobody in the audience, nobody outside
of Taylor's like main audience would see Centress as any kind
of slight anyway. So, realistically, you're not even communicating
something there. It's a totally worthless conversation to have
in the first place. But now that we're having it, okay, the thing
she said was not a lie. And these people have totally invented
something to be upset about because they got blown out by
they got blown out by the valley girl buzzsaw once again. Okay,
they walked right into the buzzsaw, right into the wood chipper.
Um, it just seems like you guys don't really understand journalism.
And maybe if you just knew a little bit more about journalism,
maybe you wouldn't look kind of silly right now. I'm just saying.
I just said maybe touch Hud you you asked me why we doing this
question. I don't want to get into this. So are you asking me?
Do you want me to give an answer for why we're doing this or
do you not want me to answer that? >> Why are you nitpicking
the most meaning meaningless things when you already agree that
she did? >> It's not it's not meaningless. Dude, you have
to actually be incapable of understanding. It's so sad to watch.
It's so >> did it for a specific reason and it was dishonest
because you asked me. So I'll answer that. The reason why we're
going down this drain is because you asked me why I interjected.
And why I interjected has to do with your method of reasoning,
not your conclusions. And so obviously to analyze your method
of reasoning, we need to get into your reasoning. And that's
involves criticizing it. And so that's why we're getting into
it is because that's why I interjected. And you wanted to inquire
as to why I did it, right? Wait, why is why is that unbelievable?
I'm going to get I'm actually going to get banned off of kick.
I'm actually going to get banned off of kick. I'm actually going
to get banned off of kick. I'm actually going to get banned off
of kick. I'm actually going to get banned off of kick. This guy
just did he just did a face. He just did a face instead of responding.
You just did a face toire. >> He just did a face. He just
did a face.
>> Wait, why is Why is that unbelievable? That's exactly
like if I >> Dude, I'm like I'm like going to start hyperventilating.
Yeah, this is maximum cortisol spike. >> I imagine you
having a conversation with
Rob No, whatever. And he comes on live and learn and he you ask
him a question and he debate bros himself into the most ridiculous
thing possible. Like I I >> She didn't even do that. and
and these people I think it's I actually think it's their bias
that's leading them in this direction too.
I feel like I like I know she got a little like she was not wanting
to answer, but that seemed way more like she was defensive because
of the the like forcefulness of the questioning like that Hutch
was clearly trying to get her.
You know, you know what I'm saying? Like Hutch was clearly trying
to get her and I feel like it was that was why she got defensive
more so than any
like unassalable logic on Hutch's part. personally would not
in like if I if I if I thought that you had like a better point
to make or you had already belabored the point it was time to
move on to something like that maybe I would interject and be
like okay do you have another like descriptive that you want
to go with I would never in a million years jump in to like offer
Rob no a lifeline and start like nitpicking your >> I'm
not offering my intent wasn't to offer a lifeline I'm telling
you in effect that that's what happened in fact there were multiple
times throughout that conversation where she was like you >> she
didn't get a lifeline at all she just laughed at you cuz you're
>> interject and say something and I would be like type.
She' be like, I you can't even answer. She would be like, you
can't even answer that.
>> She was clinging to
>> Is Pisco married? Could you imagine? Will you be my
wife? Yes or no? Will you do me the honor of marrying me? Yes
or >> She was clinging on to the things that you were saying.
And so she was like, "Oh, it's just you." It's funny how you
don't want to do that. So she was definitely like clinging to
that like lifeboat 100,000%.
And she did it every >> If if I'm correct on a a point
and if she is playing on to that >> Well, I don't think
being right or
>> I don't I don't think you were being correct. Like I
I don't think you were correct on those points. >> That's
going to turn on whether or not I I am correct or not. And that's
going to involve us talking about it. So >> that's besides
the point in the weeds. >> The correctness or the incorrectness
doesn't matter. Like I I just I would never I would never like
>> like I would never interject in a way that was another
way another way what you're doing is saying don't countermand
me when I'm closing on my kill. Right. You're like because she
can cling on to anything I say.
It's just like it's just so obvious that that's what they wanted
to do and that's why the whole thing was set up the way it was.
They all sit back and like there was no attempt at having a good
faith conversation at all. It's so embarrassing. Pisco would
be so embarrassed if he said that. I hope I hope the rest of
Live and Learn is embarrassed, man.
Like like I know Josiah would never publicly like
[__] on Hutch for saying this, but I feel like I
know in my heart of hearts that is not how he wants anyone around
him to operate.
I Yeah, I don't think IRI cares. I I literally I feel like he'd
be like, "Hey man, that helps Democrats, man. Let's >> It's
a lifeline, right? It's like don't talk. Why are you talking?
>> Well, no, no, not necessarily. Like I'm not saying
>> quiet. So you're like you would be you would be cool
if I spoke up to her. Yeah, you just agreed with that frame.
That's crazy. >> No, you you can >> That is the framing.
That is what he was going for. Yeah, that's 100% what he was
going for is he wanted a scalp and you interrupted him trying
to take a scalp to point out that he was like kind of By the
way, this is this all opens up the idea that Hutch was operating
in bad faith explicitly and he was upset because Pisco was pointing
out that the line of questioning was not going to lead to a productive
result and that all Hutch wanted was to go after this person.
That's it. This is totally disqualifying. Like, like realistically,
that makes your show look deranged. Your show is garbage because
this is out here saying like this. I that
there's no way he just said that. Why the would he say that?
They wanted to sl I I said this when I watched it. Holy uh Holy
Xray. I said that this is far more like a sling interview than
anything else I've seen. like this is like but oh wait I said
it was more like a Sloan interview. I do think Taylor knew it
was going to be contentious at points. Like I think he knew they
disagreed on the chorus article. I don't think she thought she
was coming on to like have somebody try to kill her as Hutch
just said, right? He's just given up all pretense that he was
attempting to approach this in good faith. It's just sad. >> You
jump in and interject and if you think my I can sharpen my argument
in a different way. That's fine. But don't do the like yes or
no thing and then when I start to give you a nuance answer you
yes or no like what are we doing then? Like we're just h like
now the whole the whole vibe is completely now now I'm like dealing
with you and I'm like you know I I got to
>> dude exactly lol
dude I like this is by the way this is why I say anybody in that
space like I
it's funny cuz they don't have arguments but also this is what
happens because they don't have arguments is they are totally
willing to just be to say anything to do anything to with people
like this is this is just deranged. I I as much as I thought
Hutch was a like an little loser, I didn't think it was this.
I I didn't think it was this. >> Balance these two things
at the same >> Yeah. Regardless of whether you're saying
irrespective of whether you're correct, right? You're saying
regardless of whether you're correct, don't ask me tough questions
when I'm closing in on my kill. >> Not in the way that
you did. No, definitely not.
>> Like this is maybe the best part of Hutch being a is
he is saying things that are that are basically disqualifying
him right as a like honest goodfaith political interlocutor
and he doesn't even realize it. He doesn't even realize the kind
of he's saying I have to I actually have to back it up.
>> So now I'm like dealing with you and I'm like you know
I I got to balance the >> I I have to back it up. I have
to send this time stamp to
some some friends. basically.
Yeah. Regardless of whether you're saying irrespective of whether
you're correct, right? You're saying regardless of whether you're
correct, >> don't ask me tough questions when I'm closing
in on my kill. >> Not in the way that you did. No, definitely
not. >> And and I don't do that is because >> cuz
you because you you
up the whole vibe. You [__] up the whole flow. I
had a whole [__] I had a whole thing. >> You
had plenty of time. H And on your own accord. >> You're
distracting me. You're coming in and you're like yes or no. No.
No. And I'm my my brain is very very focused on what Taylor is
saying, where I'm going with it. I have like a plan. It was very
methodical. And now I got like Biden, yes or no, you and then
I try to do like the nuanced answer.
>> No, you were condescending. Every time Pisco asks you
a question, you were condescending as Beast. You're a prick.
>> And you're talking to me like Rob No. You know what
I mean? Like I just would I just don't do that. Like if you're
if you want to sharpen my argument, just do it in a way that's
not so like >> All right, Substance. I'm sorry. I'm sorry,
Substance. My bad. You do great work, Substance. I don't I didn't
mean to get on you. That's my bad. Honestly, there are other
Clippers. Where are the other Clippers at? There's like eight
other Clippers. Where are the Clippers?
Where the is everybody? >> Cuz it's distracting as is my
point. >> Well, listen. I I have no If what you're saying
is like it doesn't matter whether you're right or wrong. Just
like don't ask me the questions that I would also ask of No,
that's not what I'm saying. Of a guest. >> I didn't say
that. >> I said the tone. Just how you do it. Just how
you do it. If you're like if you jump in and you're like h I
think I don't think you're making the point the best way. If
you do that, that that's fine. Like that's direct. That's not
going to blow up the conver. >> That's what he did. >> That's
But no, that's not what he did. You do like yes or no. >> The
first dude, again, just the complete and total gaslighting. The
complete and
gaslighting. This is the first >> interjection issue with
like random sort of characterizations. And again, I >> I
don't think it was random. I think it was deliberate. I think
it was
>> Why don't you get to there? I mean, like I mean, why
don't you go there and just ask Taylor the copy editor? >> I'm
trying to have a conversation with her. I don't know why you're
jumping in >> No, no, no. Because it's kind >> He's
totally disingenuous. He's He's just lying. >> Biden, did
he do the thing yesterday? >> No, that's what I did. I'm
saying like So, you wouldn't have an issue with that? You wouldn't
have an issue being like, um, for me, okay, it's just specifically
like getting you to answer whether Joe Biden is or is not uh
centrist on your own view in a way that by the way, the point
I do that is I think it's a quick way to show that, huh, actually,
maybe this is like not as clear as I thought. Like, maybe this
is actually requires, like you said, nuance and actually centrists
can mean different things in different circles. And so be like,
well, Centra is progressive. No, I understand, right? Like that's
what the question is meant to elicit and you're saying I'm thrown
by that question. That question throws me. So regardless of whether
you know, whatever happens, the question threw me. And so I didn't
like the question because of the tone of it. >> When you're
having interactions with human beings, like the tone of the interaction
is going to color >> dissension again.
>> what happens? And so when when you do the yes or no,
no, no. It's hostile. And so now I'm dealing with a hostile actor.
>> R2-D hutch. R2-D hutch. R2-D hutch. R2-D hutch. R2D
Hutch and I'm also but that's >> though Hutch I mean you're
you're you're being incredibly horrible on her >> but you're
not you know like I'm not I'm not incredibly horrible on people
on my side and not on my side like if you see me like when we're
you can be direct you can be direct without being like overtly
hostile is the point you can >> was not overtly hostile
imagine being that level of victim that you consider by the way
you hutch you were overtly hostile you Hutch are the person who
consistently was condescending and rude when Pisco was being
kind when he was just saying hey I think we should just go here
>> you can be direct without like
with the vibe and like with the flow you can just interject likely
if you would have literally would have just said hut respectfully
I think this is the best way to make the argument here's what
I would say but you're like no no this is stupid you know what
kind of question I asked of you wait do you think the kind of
question I asked with you was like inconsistent with the kind
of questions you were asking Taylor >> I don't know what
that means >> it's consistent with so the manner in which
I approached you is very like the manner you approached Taylor
>> no I was being I was being no I like watch you back,
bro. I was being kinder and calmer with her than you were with
me. You brought in a whole new energy. >> But if you're
going to take issue with like random sort of characterizations,
and again, I understand >> I think it was random. I think
it was deliberate. I think it was deliberate.
>> Why don't you get to there? I mean, like I mean, why
don't you go there and just ask Taylor?
>> I'm trying to have a conversation with her. I don't
know why you're jumping in
>> You were more hostile to me than I was to Taylor.
In fact, I think right here Hutch is almost equally hostile to
Pisco and Taylor. Like he's incredibly hostile to Pisco right
there. I like it's there's just no other way to look at it.
And this gaslighting will not stand.
>> that is I totally I totally disagree with that characterization.
You were demanding you were demanding. You're saying you're being
evasive. You're a >> Dude, Dude, dude,
did Hutch watch it back? Did he watch how condescending he was
to Pisco every single time? How could anybody I I now I'm like
now I'm starting to lose my mind. How could anybody watch Hutch
be so condescending to Pisco when he's trying to like interject
with anything and then go actually Pisco is being really rude
to Hutch here. Pisco is really with Hutch
>> That was after that. That was after >> you're
not answering my question. >> That was No, that was after
that. I That was after that. I promise you. I was so composed.
Like I was so composed. She was the one that was flailing. I
I kept my calm and zen. I did that consciously and then I had
you come in like that's not how I perceived it. And so and and
so if that's the case, I'll rewatch it and see if I think that
the manner in which I approached with you was in with the manner
you approached Taylor. That was not how I understood it. Now
maybe it is. I could be wrong in terms of how I was remembering
it. But you would say if I approach you in the manner that you
were approaching Taylor, you you wouldn't have a problem from
a VI perspective, right? If it's the case that we were approaching
it from similar angles, you to tailor me to you.
>> Ask that question again. There's a lot of moving parts
here. >> So if it's the case, right? So assume it's the
case that the manner in which you were asking in the form of
the questions that you were asking teller is roughly similar
to how I asked it of you, you wouldn't have a vibe based reason
to object to it. Correct. Cuz it would be inconvenent
with your vibe. I mean I even then I think following the vibe
that you're saying you're my podcast host
we're >> host but she's our guest
>> and you are being a total prick to peace >> like
the the the usual form in terms of inviting people on to guest
is to treat the guest better than you treat the co-host. That's
the usual form. >> I did. I did. >> What a lying
piece of dude. This guy is just scum. Total scum, man. I I kind
of went back and forth on this guy being an [__]
before this or like an or a like just dumb, but he's actually
scum. Like actual scum. Total scum. Is it treat the guest better
than you treat the co-host? That's the usual form. >> I
did. I did. I I like I was so calm with her. I was so like I
I did not like at any point did you hear especially when at the
point that you jumped in, was the tone that I was using with
Taylor, was I doing stuff like yes or no, Taylor? Yes or no?
Like I'm not sure if you use the term yes or no. >> Dude,
imagine falling back to
saying yes or no is actually the abusive behavior. Saying yes
or no is like the abusive evil behavior here, dude. I Okay. >> Oh
no, you were asking direct question. Whether you use the term
yes or no can't be what this is turned on. Really? Is that really
what's going to turn on? Is whether I said yes or no? >> It's
not about the specific whether you did or didn't. >> It's
not about the specific language. It is like very pointed and
hostile and hostile like you did, right? Like you didn't kill
her. No, I'm not saying no. You were more haggro with me than
I was with her. A thousand%.
>> This is just not true.
And like I understand I like I'm even willing to admit that I
don't help their friendship resolve better or something by covering
this. But unfortunately I have to watch everybody everybody every
single person who's willing to talk publicly
gaslight Pisco and pretend that he's the problem when this sick
degenerate addict who is only using his addict behaviors. It's
all of his It's all of his maladapted a maladapted maladaptive
addict behaviors are taking root here, taking hold, and he is
doing them again and again. He is just willing to warp reality
to where he's the pro he's not the problem. He's the victim.
It's so to watch.
It's soed
up to watch this loser try to gaslight somebody who's who's trying
to have honest conversations while he like openly with the reputation
of their show. openly says the dumbest imaginable, openly has
no interest in any intellectual conversation, is only engaging
in thought termination, and is trying to use essentially like
populist tactics to attack anybody who disagrees with them. It
it just it just strains credul for me to like I don't understand
the impulse like after someone who has established themselves
to be not operating in good faith and being deceptive and being
evasive and giving crazy answers like to then to redirect that
energy towards me and be like you know like it is like
>> whenever whenever there's a dispute that's just how
I always act and that's how I always am. And it's >> I
would take a look at that. That's all I'm saying.
>> And I don't know what else to say at this point. I think
I've said all of it. >> Oh, I'm in fight mode. That's that's
presupposing the first is is intended to be a pounce. I I understand
okay maybe how I approach it uh you know is is really not conducive
to to good discourse. I mean maybe but like the whole point of
these questions is to make it clear what the claims are. If the
claim is that it's factually correct or incorrect that she's
a centrist or moderate whether you're claiming it's standard
whether you're claiming that the contract says there's no disclosure
or whether the course of dealing was that there's no enforcement
of that provision like I don't understand why we just can't get
clarity on the views and that's what I was trying to do. Most
of the time I didn't interrupt your flow and a lot of the times
he performed beautifully. I thought that the I wasn't trying
to go about and if I was just trying to do that, I would have
interrupted at the most devastating moments when you were absolutely
destroying her on the Israel point and I didn't do that because
you were cooking.
>> Okay. Well, listen. >> I got to I got to get going
here pretty soon. I didn't expect this conversation. This is
another one of our [__] listen. Yeah, I enjoy the
conversation here. The only thing I ask like I am not asking
for you to like go easy on me. That's not what I'm saying. I
like being directly challenged.
I would question sometimes. That's all I'm saying. I would just
question sometimes the level of hostility
maybe just like four notches below that would like help. That's
all I'm asking. Just you know so embarrassing given how aggressive
he was on Pisco. So embarrassing from for him to pretend and
gaslight in the other direction.